billionaire Michael Bloomberg was a late
entrant to the Democratic primary and he
is polling 7% in a recent poll after
spending reportedly around a hundred
million dollars on advertising for his
campaign and this tells us many things
it tells us that you can buy your way
into a campaign but not necessarily past
one percent we'll talk about that
Bloomberg combining his money with at
least some notoriety to buy his way all
the way up to 7% this tells us that at
least in some sense the idea of fighting
Trump with a better billionaire is
appealing to some people
7% anyway and it also confirms that when
you were polling one to two percent for
like a year during the campaign you're
probably not going anywhere
and so Delaney and Williamson Bennett
Castro steyr and gebardi should probably
drop out at this point in time the
newest Quinnipiac poll out yesterday has
Biden at 30 Warren at 17 Sanders at 16
booted judge at 9 and Michael Bloomberg
at 7 percent in what is essentially a
statistical tie for fourth place within
the margin of error with Peter Budaj
edge andrew yang and Amy Amy Klobuchar
each with 3% Cory Booker at 2 Gabbard at
1 steyr at 1 Castro at 1 now another
interesting thing about this is that
even though you can buy your way in not
just anyone can do it because Tom Styer
has also spent a ton of money not nearly
as much as Bloomberg but he can't get
past 1% so to buy your way in it can't
just be money it has to be money in
something else more questions now about
whether Michael Bloomberg will ever have
an opportunity to debate because
remember he is not accepting individual
contributions therefore he cannot
qualify based on the current rules that
the DNC has established with growing
donor thresholds as we get further and
further into the print of the primary
debate period and so there are now more
and more questions about whether the DNC
will or should change its rules now I
said before if the DNC now says hey you
know what
even though Michael Bloomberg doesn't
have donors at least in the formal sense
that you need them in order to qualify
for the debates he's polling 7% let's
figure out a way to get him into the
debates because he's polling 7% the
other candidates would and should
rightly go absolutely crazy
now if the DNC doesn't make any change
you will end up with a candidate that is
effectively tied for fourth place within
the margin of error with Pete Budaj
not in the debates both are wacky
scenarios now I've said before I don't
think we need another billionaire
running from a political analysis from a
logic analysis having a candidate tied
for fourth place who is not in the
debates is strange but these are the
rules of the game they have been
established by the DNC I've previously
been critical that they weren't strict
enough in getting some of the zeros and
ones out of the debates early enough and
now you know live by these rules die by
these rules unless they say hey let's
just change these rules to accommodate
one particular person which they may or
may not do the the other question is
it's not really clear the DNC wants
Michael Bloomberg in there Michael
Bloomberg's presence certainly has the
the risk of hurting Joe Biden and Pete
Budaj edge the establishment candidates
more than it has the potential to hurt
Bernie Sanders and Elizabeth Warren
based on the numbers I've seen so far
there are different numbers by all means
send them to me so it's not clear to me
that the DNC aside from the logic of if
you're polling 7% tied for fourth place
statistically should you be in aside
from that it's not clear from a
strategic perspective the DNC would even
really want Michael Bloomberg in the
debates but with the latest poll
Quinnipiac Michael Bloomberg already
polling 7% one of our sponsors is
privacy calm they're giving you $5 when
you sign up for their completely free
service at privacy calm slash Pakman
I've been using privacy for a little
over a year now you've heard me talk
about it before it's a life saver and
here's how it works takes just a couple
of minutes to set up anytime you buy
something online or on the phone
instead of actually using your real
credit card number the privacy app and
the browser plugin let you give each
company a randomized virtual credit card
number that you create out of thin air
it'll even autofill the card number with
one click and the payment is taken out
of your checking account without the
merchant ever knowing your real
information so this allows you to keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create up to 12 of these virtual credit
cards a month you can set spending
limits you can freeze them you can
delete them anytime you want so when you
do this it means you're not going to be
charged when you don't want to be
because you can destroy the virtual card
number right after using it which for
instance I love using free trials
because I know I won't be charged when
the trial is over if I use a virtual
credit card number you're keeping your
identity private by not telling
companies who you are you're keeping
your bank or credit card info protected
against data breaches and identity theft
and it's free there's no catch
whatsoever but if you want privacy also
offers a $10 a month plan that gives you
one percent cashback and lets you create
36 credit cards a month and a $25 a
month plan tailored more for small
businesses where you can create 60 card
numbers a month and much more but
definitely go ahead and at least get
started with the free plan you'll
protect your financial info companies
can't charge you unexpectedly and like I
said you'll get $5 to spend when you
sign up at privacy calm / Pakman